yeah how was how was your perception of
england going back i wrote notes i wrote
your notes your wrong numbers you wrote
notes oh this is why you wanted chris
told me to write notes my phone is on
one percent um
you're gonna read them also what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna read through them all
then we can talk about it okay very very
dirty lovely
london is really loud i didn't realize
how noisy it was before it feels like
the same amount of people are walking
around tokyo but but in london it's less
orderly yeah lots more homeless
people making gestures or saying
something to you whenever you do
anything like when i this guy just
started talking to me in in the
in the lift and i was really confused
and i i just forgot that that was like a
thing that was like
he started just talking to him and i was
like i'd literally just checked into my
hotel just going off the flight i was
like what did he say to you he was just
like he was talking about like um did
you say hi
he's like oh hi hi how you doing i'm
like
so funny say that cause i literally got
recommended a video like yesterday of
this satire like news report that's just
like northerner terrorizes londoners by
saying hello
literally what happened oh yeah
people would
people okay when they bump into you
right in japan right yeah and i've
totally forgot this is a thing this is
the longest cable on earth man
when when people bump into you in japan
they say sorry yeah so many people
bumped into me and were just [ __ ]
and didn't say i didn't say anything i i
i could not every time that happened to
me i could not stop saying myself
it was just like it was just like muscle
memory even if i hadn't bumped into
someone i was like on the tube right and
i was like
i was like i was like i'm not in japan
anymore i need to stop doing this
because no one else is saying this [ __ ]
but like i just couldn't stop saying it
or like subconsciously uh i had um one
thing that happens in japan now i don't
expect this so i i just i just noticed
that it was different when you get a
taxi in japan the taxi driver will
always try and help you with your bags
even if you don't need it right yeah it
could be the smallest bag on earth and
he might try and come out and help you
with it yeah um and like never happened
with taxis in the uk i know i was every
time i had a suitcase or anything they'd
just sit in the car and then i'd have to
open the boot too as well which is fine
i'm totally fine with that but i just
thought i was like oh yeah yeah there's
a thing that we don't do right
um and that was most of them yeah that
was
the most i'll tell you the biggest the
the immediate thing
that uh i noticed about going back to
the uk that i immediately missed about
japan uh so i think it was the second
day that uh that we landed there and um
oh sorry my second day in the uk we uh
went out to just
walk around brighton again walk around
town uh because it's been uh quite a
while since i've been in my hometown so
me and cindy just went out
did a quick shopping trip and uh i got i
got thirsty my throat was a little bit
parched right okay and so i started
searching for a drink
in order to quench my thirst right and i
look around and i'm just like
where are the vending machines
how how am i supposed to procure some
liquids so that's
so that's how they quench my thirst
right and i walk around in this shopping
center and i'm like wait and then i soon
realized i have to go to a shop yeah in
order to purchase some liquid it's not
even a convenience store like a
supermarket yeah they're like like a
corner shop yeah yeah yeah i'm just like
well what backwood system is this you
know yeah i i need to go to go into a
shop that sells other things other than
drinks and uh i need to do human
interaction in order to purchase this
like what what what is this we really do
take for granted how many [ __ ]
vending machines are on this car i
didn't realize that because like
sometimes i'm just walking around i get
i get a little thirsty and i'm just like
literally a minute away from the next
vending machine i didn't realize how
convenient that was until i went to the
uk
and like it's like it's in a big
shopping center most of this is just
like clothes or like different different
kind of stores that are not like food
drink items and even if there is most of
them are like you know something like
super drug or some some very big you
know pharmacy store where they sell they
sell drinks there but it's a it's way
bigger than it needs to be so i end up
like having to go in go into this
massive store get go to like the small
segments just for food and drink and
then and then line up yeah and i'm just
like disgusting disgusting
not on my watch
but that is like the first thing i
noticed where it was just like i i
really missed vending machines and just
like being able to like buy you know
very conveniently buy a like a snack i
felt that way as well when like whenever
i go back to australia or the or like
the us or anything as well because like
we have vending machines like in
australia in the us yeah but you don't
have like a suica yeah
[ __ ] reach in grab your [ __ ]
change jiggle that around and then yeah
i don't know why they got your fired
[ __ ] vending machines in the west
because sometimes the drink doesn't even
[ __ ] yeah
that's true so i'm like oh good i'm
about to gamble three dollars to see if
i can even sometimes you get a double
pool as well
that just happens sometimes you're
really lucky
oh like you you buy a drink and you're
like i'm gonna buy another drink
immediately but then but then the
machine is designed in such a way that
it just can't handle two drinks being
dispensed at once so you have to like
[ __ ] scrunch your hand inside and
like pull one out yeah just so you can
unblock this [ __ ] thing yeah but i
noticed as well obviously like i i got
out of the airport and just like no one
was wearing masks really yup yup no
and that not that i you know i don't i
don't have a [ __ ] opinion on it i do
whatever i'm told to do right i'm a
sheep all right what can i say
wake up sheep that's taking a stance in
the self-care i guess i don't give a
[ __ ] i'm just like if everyone around me
is wearing a mask i'll wear a mask you
know what i mean but it was one of those
things where i was like oh
whoa this is [ __ ] weird and like yeah
because in japan it's like you know
you you'll be crucified if you don't
wear them you could be in the middle of
a rice field and they'll still help
fight exactly and like it was just like
so strange just seeing everything kind
of back to normal it was like the uk
just took the route of we don't give a
[ __ ] anymore open back up
but was also it was but the rules are
different as well between england and
wales and because i was traveling
between them
on welsh trains you have to wear a mask
on english trains you don't have to wear
a mask but some trains go from wales to
england so what happens is is that when
you get into england people just took
off their masks on the terrain
so
which does nothing which then just
eliminates the whole point of you know
yeah where i was like you know i'm not
that i i
think one or one of either is wrong or
right i'm just like it
invalidates for both if you have to put
it on or off yeah yeah you're on the
same goddamn train it was yeah or
whatever
that was enough that's that's like you
being on a flight and then like oh we're
we're now in russian airspace
like okay
and i was wearing a mask
and i thought this was only in like uh
in america but someone came up to me and
was like take off your mask
what yeah someone came up to me like
take off your mask and i was like i
don't think i will and then he was like
why he was where were you oh i was in
wales all right he was saying so yeah
well you have to wear milestone stolen
worlds no no no you don't oh you just
did anyway but no right um i was like
the only person wearing a mask right
yeah um i because i also i look like
[ __ ] i wanted to cover my face
i felt dreadful but he came up to me and
he was like take off your mask and i was
like no and then he was like why why are
you wearing a mask and i was like i just
ignored him i was just like i carried on
my phone and i was just like are you on
the train uh no no outside the train
station
you just like take off your mask and i
was like no
why i don't know some people get weirdly
offended by it
it's like sorry i'm protecting myself
yeah you know like one time i was
wearing it as well and the guy asked me
uh he was like are you wearing that for
me or for you and i was like
for me
i mean both technically because the
thing was is that even though you know
that because we had a flight to get on
so i was coming up to that flight i was
like i'm wearing a mask because yeah i
do not want to get yeah of course be
having to rearrange all my plans and
delay yeah of course so that's why i was
wearing it and then i was like oh my god
i was like why are so many people
[ __ ] coming up to me and telling me
to take off my mess because you're
taking a stance and like i think i think
going back to england because i had very
similar experiences
where um every time
every time like every time i'd meet like
some group of uh some group of friends
they'd question me of like why i chose
to wear a mask
why i chose to put on this mask
they didn't listen to me until i put on
the mask
and so like i would get questioned about
it and i'm just like i don't know i just
i need to fly back to japan
i'm pretty used to it and i just don't
want to take any risks i don't know like
this that's just my my uh
my opinion man like
it's like why do you have to be like
accused for protecting yourself like i'm
not saying that's like being like why
are you wearing the condom yeah take it
off
it's like i'm going around being like
put your mask on put your mouth i don't
give a [ __ ] you don't need to if you
don't if the government tells you you
don't need to wear it i don't give a
[ __ ] don't wear it i'm just going to
wear it but the government also says
don't wear a mask yeah like it's not
like they they're you know they're going
to [ __ ] you know take your mask away
i just feel i just feel like what i've
realized going back home at least in
england it was it became very like
political yeah like like it's it's like
as you know as everything does but i
feel like we got sheltered from that in
japan because everyone here wears a mask
um
and
everyone here wore a mask before kovid
and that's why it was like super easy to
just integrate that into society whereas
um like people just don't like being
told what to do in england
you know
america as well you know it's it's it
was it was something where just doing
this one thing like wearing a mask was
like
in the in in that environment you were
making a statement or a stance or a
choice
that was conscious i guess and i just
never really it's like what about it
that deeply i get that but it's like i
don't know why that is you know subject
to ridicule or criticism right it's like
it's not like you're doing something bad
by protecting yourself yeah i don't know
i i i it was it was weird i didn't know
it was the other way around right yeah
i mean this is
the way i looked at it was not even a
political sense i was just like i just
want to wear it because i want to wear
it [ __ ] off yeah like like you're
wearing a hat would you tell me i can't
wear a hat like yeah yeah you know
like [ __ ] what are you hiding yeah
like like me before going to england i'd
never really thought about it that
deeply
i think i've thought about you know the
difference between chicken breasts and
chicken thighs more deeply than wearing
a mask you know that's you should have
just turned around and go being like it
ain't that deep bro
i'm just wearing a mask off my back i
thought i was just like no i was like
leave me alone
rip the mask off of you
oh my god i couldn't believe it i was
just like [ __ ] off jesus